the business is doing roughly what per
year seven mil it's great it's 40 of us
yeah it's a big-ass business
well I don't even like the way you said
that my god do you know how many [__]
people ever on Earth from the [__]
brain and soul go out and build a
business doing seven million a year you
better say that [__] with way more Pride
[__] all this crazy [__] you understand
yeah I know that I thought you built it
from zero yeah
please promise me if nothing else yeah
yeah if we never connect right can you
promise me that you never say that again
the way you just did yeah I like that I
like that 99 of people go to zero yeah I
appreciate you saying yeah I know how
hard it is zero to seven oh that's big I
know the world tells you it's not how
old are you 53 now yeah the same way the
world tells you that you're old and
you're a baby you stood about 50 more
years yeah I believe that yeah same way
that seven should never be said like
that again my God